mein problem das eigentlich dass es so
staatlich verordnetes weihnachten gibt
wir feiern nicht das worauf wir uns alle
berufen können auch einmal die wir hier
stehen die tage werden wieder länger
aber es ist auch die fußbodens in der
deutung fähigkeit der firma kurz
erklären wofür weihnachten feiere als
christen an weihnachten dass gott mensch
wird und für mich ist es auch ein sehr
politisches fest
falls ist weihnacht aber jetzt mal
ernsthaft feiern wir weihnachten noch
aus religiösen gründen oder feiern wir
nur noch den kapitalismus und was ist
eigentlich mit den vielen menschen in
diesem land die nicht christlich sind
wäre es in einer modernen und diversen
gesellschaftlich angebracht dass alle
religiösen feste gleich wichtig sind
deswegen sagen meine gäste auf dem
gelben fällt heute weihnachten ganzen
aus und meine gäste auf dem grünfeld
sagen dass weihnachten unfassbar wichtig
dass ich freue mich auf jeden fall sehr
auf die diskussion und wie immer geht
meine erste frage von 13 fragen an euch
wie wichtig ist euch dann weihnachten
schreibt mir in die kommentare
sie beginnen mit der positions- runde
wenn ihr eine einer dieser also meine
erste frage zustimmt dann geht er einen
schritt auf sie befällt und wenn ihr der
frage nicht zustimmt geht ein schritt
aus grünefeld sollte die kirche ihre
vormachtstellung in deutschland aufgrund
unserer multireligiösen gesellschaft
aufgeben wenn er sagt ja dann ein
schritt ins gelbe fällt und dann gesagt
nein dann ein schritt ins koma fällt
[Musik]
ich finde schon dass es an der zeit ist
dass köche ihre vormachtstellung in
deutschland aufgibt weil wir
mittlerweile ganz viele menschen haben
die gar nicht mehr christlich sind oder
mitglied in der küche sind für mich hat
die küche keine vormachtstellung und
zwar deshalb weil ich mich als
von der küche nicht grenzt oder sogar
unterdrückt fühle sondern frei handeln
kann in diesem land schließen wir mit
unserem weihnachts kult andere
religionen aus dadurch dass weihnachten
ein christliches fest ist und dass hier
auch sehr sehr sehr sehr viel gefeiert
wird schließt man automatisch im
menschen die eine andere religion haben
auch automatisch aus ich glaube wir
brauchen immer noch weihnachten genauso
wie andere religiöse feste um als
familie oder als freundesgruppe
zusammenzukommen zusammen zu essen
zusammen zu feiern gemeinschaft zu
erleben und uns bewusst machen dass es
etwas größeres gibt und wir brauchen
etwas das über uns als einzel menschen
hinaus geht sollten christliche feste in
deutschland vom staat nicht mehr
bevorzugt werden als andere religiöse
feste was sagt ihr ja oder nein
wir schließen durchaus andere religionen
mit unserem weihnachtsgeld aus zumal
wenn leute sich halt bewusst dazu
entscheiden nicht weihnachten zu feiern
sie halt als die abi gemacht sind oder
wald als fremd also ich finde nicht dass
man weihnachten als staatlichen feiertag
aufgeben musste ich würde es aber noch
schöner finden wenn wir noch weitere
feiertage aus anderen kulturen mit als
staatliche feiertage aufnehmen
[Musik]
euro positionen sind klar jeder draußen
mich wieder natürlich interessieren wo
würdet ihr euch hinstellen hier auf dem
feld gelb oder grün
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare wir
eröffnen jetzt hier die nächste runde
und dieser runde geht es darum wir
wissen jetzt schon wo ihre positionen
sind eure position vielleicht schon mal
zu hinterfragen mal gucken ob mir das
gelingt
ich beginne mit eurer seite kirche und
staat und in deutschland getrennt es
gibt also keine offizielle
staatsreligion ist es denn dann fährt
das unser weihnachts raus so präsent ist
dass alle anderen religiösen festtage
quasi keine rolle spielen schon gar
nicht offiziell
was sagt ihr wenn ihr mir zustimmt dann
könnt ihr jetzt ein schritt auf mich zu
gehen oder ihr bleibt stehen und er sagt
nie absoluter schrott ich gehe noch
einen schritt nach hinten
du sagst nein sagt ja warum
ich finde wir leben mittlerweile
wirklich in einer geöffneten multikulti
welt wir sind in der globalisierung und
da finde ich es wichtig achtung vor auch
den anderen feiertagen zu haben
dass weihnachten so präsent ist ist ja
nicht nur etwas was die kirchen wollen
sondern was vor allen dingen eine
konsumkultur geschaffen hat der
weihnachtsmann kommt nicht in der bibel
vor den hat coca cola erfunden ich
glaube dass das ein wichtiger grund
dafür ist warum weihnachten so groß ist
ich finde andere religionen sollten auch
feiertage haben die dann frei sind und
begangen werden öffentlich ok dann
möchte ich jetzt eure position
hinterfragen das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt dass zur
religionsfreiheit auch die freie
religionsausübung gehört das heißt doch
eigentlich alle können an ihren
feiertagen frei nehmen egal
glauben sie haben bewusst das problem
oder was sagt ihr wenn ihr zustimmt dann
könnte ersten schritt auf mich zugehen
stimmt er nicht na ja also das was quasi
vielleicht rechtlich was vielleicht in
der verfassung festgeschrieben ist
das geht nun also die religionsausübung
die ist ja garantiert was allerdings
nicht garantiert das ist ja die
privilegierung die dann noch dazu kommt
das heißt klar man kann im yom kippur
man kann das zuckerfest privat natürlich
feiern aber kann ich mir halt dadurch
auch einen ganzen freien tag hat
irgendwie mit meiner familie nehmen ohne
dass ich mir irgendwie ein urlaubstag
von meiner urlaubskasse dann dafür
einplanen muss nein kann ich nicht
können dass christen so die zum beispiel
hält auch in ihrer familie dann
weihnachten feiern haben sie dieses
privileg ja haben sie ich möchte jetzt
in die nächste runde übergehen das ist
die persönliche runde und da hat jeder
von euch möglichkeit einmal vielleicht
auf eine persönliche motivation und
geschichte zu erzählen ich wenn ihr was
richtig scheiße findet was jemand sagt
dann geht gern schritt zurück oder geht
einen schritt auf die zu auch wenn ihr
es gut findet ihr könnt die ganze zeit
euch auf diesem feld bewegen wie
betrifft euch das thema weihnachten denn
persönlich ist euch das total egal dass
das der offizielle feiertag ist oder
hättet ihr gerne noch andere feiertage
die auch offiziell gemacht werden dann
lass es uns sehr gerne wissen
rebecca ich fange mit die an du bist
juden oder ja genau wann hast du dich
dann mit deinem glauben in unserer
gesellschaft ausgeschlossen gefühlt
ich erinnere mich dass einmal jom kippur
mit einer klausur zusammen gefallen ist
und am ende habe ich frei bekommen aber
der prozess dass sich an diesem tag frei
bekomme und die klausuren nachschreiben
darf war sehr lang und sehr anstrengend
oder jetzt studieren momentan es gibt
öfters blockseminare die samstag sind
und ich bin weiß ich ob serviere
schabbat ergo arbeite ich samstag lich
und wenn ich dann e-mail-anfragen stelle
kommt halt oft zurück ja sie sind halt
allein da müssen sie sich halt irgendwie
also sind halt die einzige also suchen
sie sich einen anderen kurs und ich habe
das kann halt nicht sein und man sollte
irgendwie ein bisschen mehr bewusst
in der führung der gesellschaft haben
was sagt ihr dann auf der seite dazu
geht er einen schritt auf rebecca zu
also überzeugt euch das also ich finde
gibt sich über bienen an denn die die
helfen bei templin oder sowas
also die leute die euch helfen beim
schabbat licht anmachen fahrstuhl und
steve jobs gollia aber kräuter ist
einfach nur andere nicht also mein leben
aber sie haben jetzt also ich finde ich
heute einen kriegen der das für euch
übernimmt finanz und ziemlich im seminar
ja dass du dein rad fahren kannst du das
ist jemand würde ich mach das ist ein
privileg das darf so finde ich meine
meinung man muss das support
was sagst du ich finde das auch auf
jeden fall eine diskriminierung wenn
darauf nicht rücksicht genommen wird für
mich wäre das auch ganz schlimm an
karfreitag zum beispiel irgend eine
klausur schreiben zu müssen oder
deswegen irgendein seminar nicht
besuchen zu können soll
was würdet ihr denn helfen oder bäcker
dass du dich weniger ausgeschlossen
fühlen würde
ich finde man sollte mehr sichtbarkeit
für andere feiertage oder weltanschauung
auch geben also zb im kalender wenn ich
den kalender in deutschland kaufen sind
dann meistens nur die christlichen
feiertage drin
und warum steht da nicht das zuckerfest
drin warum steht da nicht drin wenn
ramadan ist solche dinge würde ich gut
finden aber warum nur größeres
bewusstsein zu schaffen und ich finde es
sollte ein schulfach geben was
weltanschauung mehr thematisiert und
nicht zum beispiel nur
religionsunterricht der dann halt von
jemandem der evangelische oder
katholische theologie studiert hat auf
andere religionen blickt sondern das
anders aufgearbeitet okay weil bei mir
war es zum beispiel so in meiner
grundschule gab es nur evangelischen
grund evangelischen religionsunterricht
und man konnte dann wählen entweder man
ist da hingegangen oder zu deutsch
förderunterricht
[Gelächter]
den kindergarten meiner tochter
es ist ein bilingualer kindergarten das
heißt es sind ganz viele
unterschiedliche nationen auch dort
wieder vertreten sind und die kinder
feiern wirklich über das gesamte jahr
alle möglichen feiertage auch also nicht
religiöse sondern kulturelle feiertage
wie fänden keine ahnung chinesisches
neujahrsfest zum beispiel ja und dann
gibt es im foyer so ein baum den neues
baum und dann hin die wünsche an
also es geht vielmehr darum ja auch neu
geht zu entwickeln
für die tradition und rituale von
anderen kulturen und das kennen zu
lernen und damit wird der andere dann
sozusagen automatisch nicht mehr der
fremde sondern der bekannte und wenn man
damit früher anfängt muss man vielleicht
gar nicht mehr so von oben erklären was
jetzt wie eine religion ist ich glaube
so her du sagst dass in einer säkularen
also nicht religiösen gesellschaft auch
wenn wir natürlich christlich geprägt
sind in diesem land keine religion
besonders behandelt werden sollte warum
bis zu dieser meinung wenn wir halt
sagen wir wollen halt irgendwie alle
religionen gleich behandeln dann kommt
halt irgendwie das problem dass wir halt
noch viel mehr religion als nur die apra
mythischen haben und da fängt plötzlich
eine riesen problematik haid an wie man
so etwas hat regeln hast du nicht an
jemals ausgeschlossen gefühlt weil du
weihnachten nicht gefeiert hast oder
weil du nicht christlich sozialisiert
ist also klar weil an den feiertagen an
denen ich halt gerne mit meiner familie
hätte sein wollen so ich zum beispiel in
der uni sein musste oder in der schule
oder auf arbeit weil es schlicht nicht
möglich ist so einfach aber frei zu
kriegen oder halt dass das dann halt
einfach so zu feiern es ist halt kein
gesetzlicher feiertag das zuckerfest was
seit ein sehr sehr sehr sehr wichtiger
tag einfach im islam ist wenn man hat
ramadan beendet hat wir sind in einer
multikulturellen gesellschaft wir sind
in einer multireligiösen gesellschaft so
es ist so schwer gewesen zu sagen
der islam gehört auch zu deutschland so
ok schön danke christian wulff warnt
bedeutet das jetzt in der umsetzung also
mehr feiertage gesetzlich festlegen ja
wenn er ist noch unsicher
ich würde das könnte ja vielleicht noch
ein also weil dann drehen wir halt durch
noch also wenn jetzt jeder anfängt und
sagt ich hätte auch gerne noch ein
feiertag dann sind wir irgendwie bet365
feiertagen und dann stehen wir von den
kleinen könnte auch ein limit sagen also
zum beispiel das ist irgendwie drei
feiertage pro religion oder ja aber dann
was ist mit all den anderen kulturen es
gibt ja noch mehr als religion ohne
darauf dass man sich irgendwie nicht
vielleicht sollten wir erstmal anfangen
zu gucken was sind das eigentlich für
feiertage die wir haben weil wenn wenn
ich an weihnachten denke ist das ja erst
mal kein christliches fest also klar ist
das ein guter marketing gag der kirche
damals gewesen und dritten jahrhundert
war das glaube ich
als sie da christi geburt einfach mal
hingelegt haben aber es ist eigentlich
ein germanisches und auch einheimisches
fest gewesen das heißt das ist das fest
wo die tage wieder heller bären wo wir
uns zurück besinnen auf die zeit davor
und auch nach vorne gucken auch ostern
ist ja das war jetzt auch von der kirche
groß gefeiert aber war auch zuvor der
frühjahrs beginnen das frühjahrsfest was
dahinter steht das heißt also wenn man
jetzt mal guckt haben wir eigentlich gar
nicht mehr so viele feiertage die
eigentlich nur christlich sind sondern
wir haben retter wir haben relativ viele
die auch von anderen begangen werden
kann jeder feiern und die hinter ihr
könnt euch immer gerne positionieren
wenn ihr sagt finde ich einen schritt
zurückgehen oder wenn ihr zustand ist
ich sage okay weder interessiert mich
das am 21
die tage wieder länger werden was ja
schön ist aber ich muss da jetzt nicht
drei tage darauf durch drehen ja sondern
würde gerne ein tag davon sozusagen für
einen anderen neben also wie würdest du
denn an die gerechtigkeit herstellen
das ist bei individuellen fragen immer
eine ganz große frage ich würde zum
beispiel total gerne umwelt humanisten
tag feiern an der sonnenblende im sommer
am 21.06
das ist doch mein tag für mich da wird
nicht kämpfen ist so individuell von jom
kippur einigen nicht tag der
menschenrechte ist ja auch für mich
nicht ganz individuell aber dass das
wenn wir jetzt versuchen aus jeder
perspektive heraus eine lösung zu finden
für unsere feiertage wird schwierig was
er dann einfach alle feiertage
abschaffen
das müsste doch eigentlich total in die
hände spielen das ist um die
wintersonnenwende freigibt das ist um
den frühlingsanfang freigibt das kann
doch jeder selber deuten wie er möchte
ohne dass man die religiösen feiertage
deswegen abschaffen muss nennen wir sie
doch einfach nicht religiöse feiertage
sondern feiertage hat damit gar kein
thema ich glaube dass mein eindruck ist
nachdem ich jetzt ein bisschen mehr
zugehört habt die letzte zeit dass wir
jetzt irgendwie alle jünger sind und in
einem urbanen kontext unterwegs sind und
ich glaube dass es viele menschen gibt
die in baden württemberg auf dem land
wohnen oder in ostfriesland für die das
irgendwie fünf schritte zu weit ist und
ich finde das ungerecht den gegenüber
denen diese tradition sehr wichtig sind
und ich glaube ich doch prozentual mehr
menschen ausmachen als wir hier die dir
irgendwie da flexibler sind aber danke
dass du genau das anspricht weil man
nicht mehr vorstellen als also ich kenne
menschen die wohnen in hessen auf dem
land als in so starkem ag nick geprägten
freikirchen in meinen die sind nicht
gläubig das ganze dorf schaut auf sie
wenn sie nicht zum gottesdienst gehen
das ganze dorf sie sind geächtete in
diesem dorf und das sind die situationen
wie auch erzeugt werden durch gesetzlich
vom vom gesetzgeber gegeben eine
religiöse feiertage und das sind diese
aber nicht dass die wir nicht schlafen
zusammen fundamentalistischen
bibelauslegung
dem fall aber die weihnachten wird ja er
fiel auch von leuten gefeiert und ich
viele leute möchten das beibehalten die
gar nicht unbedingt so religiös sind
sondern die sagen okay wir lassen
vielleicht unsere kinder taufen weil das
ein schönes ritual ist somit gott
vielleicht gibt es irgend etwas größeres
so sicher sind wir auch nicht aber uns
ist es wichtig dass wir diese feiertage
begehen weil das auch was ist was
irgendwie für uns identitätsstiftend ist
und dass momente sind wo sie irgendwie
ein bezug zu ihrer religiosität oder
spiritualität überhaupt bekommen glaubt
dass es sowas gibt es ist auch schade
und ich wünsche mir da in einigen
gegenden irgendwie liberalere
christinnen und christen aber ich glaube
das ist ein sonder beispiel oder das ist
was was es nicht überall auf dem land in
deutschland gibt woher auch ich denke
nicht dass das ein fundamentalist innen
problem ist tatsächlich einfach aus
eigener erfahrung
und selbst wenn man mit sehr
säkularisierten menschen spricht oder
leute die selber sich atheisten als
atheistin verstehen ist der moment in
dem verfahren wird dass man kein
weihnachten feiert ein kleiner schock
moment und dann weiß man nicht so
richtig wie soll man auf das gegenüber
reagieren und dann kommt oft so ja also
um warum denn nicht bist du bist du da
wird so umgestaltet und sagt ich bin
jüdin und dann kommt so und dann wird
das wort jude schon gar nicht mehr
ausgesprochen weil das ja irgendwie
nicht geht in der deutschen gesellschaft
und dann fühlt man sich so unangenehm
berührt und du bist so krass fremde und
das sind halt keine fundamentalisten und
irgendwie zur freikirche bildung
aber ich glaube das ist wirklich so eine
allgemeine ignoranz anderen also noch
nicht verstanden zu haben dass man halt
in einem land lebt wo unterschiedliche
kulturen und denkweisen und so parallel
existieren zu meiner und vielleicht
befinden wir uns da ja also da bin ich
jetzt hoffnungsvoll an einem punkt auch
dass wir jetzt hier stehen und das
diskutieren ja ist ja vielleicht genauso
ein zeichen auch dafür dass man an einem
punkt es wohl auf dieses andere leben
der anderen auch neue also neu geblickt
wird was ich vorschlage ist das gar
nicht mehr nehmen
jeder soll an diesem freien tagen tun
was er will und wenn einem podcast hört
am ende mir auch egal das muss jeder für
sich selbst ausmachen wenn ein
christliches weihnachtsfest feiern
möchte soll er das tun wenn man das
lichterfest feiern möchte dass die tage
wieder heller werden sollte man das tun
vielleicht macht man auch eine
kombination aus island auch das ist ja
heutzutage das was viele tun das würde
das so offen lassen dass wir auch diese
hoffnung haben dass es im vollkommen
okay ist man muss nicht weihnachten das
kann noch gar nie wieder tun wer möchte
also gerade jetzt an weihnachten das was
dir die ganze zeit auf drückt es ist
weihnachten ist es weihnachten das ist
die werbung
das sind werte die im radio laufen die
meisten gar nicht besonders christlich
sind
das ist die blumen und tannenbaum
industrie aber da musst du hast uns
nichts kaufen und dann zwingt ja auch
niemand daran einen christlichen
gottesdienst zu besuchen an weihnachten
hier würde ich mich gerne mal von dir
wissen du bist atheist was ist denn dein
grundsätzliches problem mit weihnachten
für dich spielt ja auch da gerade der
kapitalismus und konsum eine große rolle
oder ja mein problem ist eigentlich dass
es so staatlich verordnetes weihnachten
gibt mein problem ist auch dass wir das
so groß machen
und so riesig vereint aber ist es
eigentlich ein individuelles fest jeder
soll die chance haben das auch
individuell zu feiern und das stimmt wir
haben das in den medien ganz groß wir
müssen da ein bisschen auch gucken dass
wir das auch nicht noch verstärken an
der stelle
weihnachten ist als aller erstes mal ein
fest der besinnung des rückblickes was
man nutzen kann aber auch nicht nutzen
muss und in erster linie im kein
christliches fürs in dem moment wie man
natürlich gesetzliche feiertage festlegt
auf basis von was auch immer welcher
kultur oder welcher religion hat man
immer menschen die dann sozusagen dem
nicht angehören dem nicht zugehörig sind
das nicht feiern möchten also das heißt
ich glaube es wäre wichtiger halt mehr
flexibilität mit dieser handvoll feiert
so bezeichnet zu geben als jetzt die
jetzt nur anders zu benennen weil dann
halt immer noch was ist jetzt mit denen
die wirklich weihnachten feiern wollen
in einem christlichen sinne oder oder
was ist mit denen die zucker dann haben
wir immer immer noch dasselbe problem
ja wenn du sagst lasst uns die behalten
wir nennen sie jetzt nur an als er das
sage ich nicht das ist mir ganz wichtig
es soll es können das gerne weiter
weihnachtsfesten das ist mir ist nur
wichtig was wir da feiern wir feiern
mich das was worauf wir uns alle berufen
können auch alle die mir hier stehen die
tage werden wieder länger
ja aber das ist auch die ursprüngliche
bedeutung 20 mal kurz erklären so für
weihnachten das weihnachtsfest bevor die
germanen innen das bevor man das auf die
umgemünzt hat dass es zur
wintersonnenwende stattfindet war es
eigentlich das fest des römischen
sonnengottes also da gibt es auch
verschiedene einflüsse noch die jetzt
nicht irgendwie leoparden sind ich heile
als christin an weihnachten dass gott
mensch wird und für mich ist es auch ein
sehr politisches fest weil er eben als
ein armes kind geboren wird was ihm die
ausgegrenzt ist und in dieser welt nicht
besonders willkommen ist
genau das update jedenfalls und von der
römischen von dem römischen imperium
unterdrückt wurde und deswegen ist auch
ein politisches fest aber für mich
äußert sich darin dass gott mich als
mensch und an die familie mensch die wir
ja alle sind lieb hat und das freilich
anders sagen können wir als es muss ja
nicht aber ich möchte nur sagen jesus
war nicht weiß muss ich sagen a men dazu
okay warum willst du karten schritt nach
hinten gegangen
ach so ja weil jesus werde wer soll sie
so bei jesus ist man halt so ein
bisschen raus als jude zu geben
er war jude menschwerdung gottes aber
ich kann finde heute nicht nach hinten
gehen weil du gesagt hast du vor just an
dem tag als pastorin was sagst du dein
hanna warum ist weihnachten so wichtig
für die deutsche identität nicht
unbedingt für die deutsche deutsche
identität aber für menschen die in einer
christlichen tradition aufgewachsen sind
es ist wichtig weil man eben gerade da
merkt es gibt etwas was über uns hinaus
geht wir sind nicht zufällig in dieser
welt sondern die gemeinschaft und
übersteigt uns und die es aufgehoben und
begründet in gott idee warum ist denn
für dich ein europa ohne weihnachten
nicht denkbar
ich würde gar nicht so weit gehen und
sagen dass es nur europäisch ist
natürlich gibt es verschiedene
wissensbestände aber für mich ist dies
ist ich mag jesus jesus ist etwas was
ich jetzt unabhängig von irgendeiner
religion generell als leere wunder
wunderschön finde und den tag kann ich
feiern und er ist auch außerhalb europas
wird ja auch gefeiert
also insofern würde ich gar nicht sagen
dass es nur in europa undenkbar ist ich
finde es einfach ja wie soll ich das
beschreiben ist es natürlich eine sehr
subjektive sehr um wissenschaftliche
erklärung aber wenn ich so sehe wie
glücklich deutsche sind montiert ohne
deutsche an weihnachten und dass ich die
meinung
das ist so schön und entspannend
insofern ja so sehr in klassischer
politischer aussagen der deutsche
glücklich zu sehen macht erst dann auch
glücklich also wurde sich schon zudem
positioniert ihr könnt auch gerne
natürlich wenn ihr wollt einen schritt
auf die idee zu gehen aber das hat was
schön dass gesagt zu jesus was ich
interessant finde und zwar glaubst du
denn dass man selbst wenn man nicht
religiöses und an nichts glaubt was von
religion lernen kann und dass man das an
weihnachten dann vielleicht auch
mitnehmen kann und was wäre das was wir
davon werden können also ich bin
definitiv ein universalist ich fühle
mich jetzt gut in allem oder auch das
göttliche oder auch also in wirklich
alle mops wissenschaft ist oder
kapitalismus oder was auch immer du
kannst immer also meiner meinung nach in
bezug dazu finden viele menschen
beschäftigen sich mit religion als
ausschlusskriterium er was macht nicht
anders oder was gibt mir irgendwie was
besonderes ich finde eigentlich das
besondere ist dass es verbindungen gibt
bzw
eine art von leben die dinge die gleich
sind die faszinieren mich weil sie mir
ein gefühl geben davon dass wir als welt
eine einheit sind und dass wir eventuell
in verschiedenen kulturen das gleiche in
wunderbarer weise verschieden
interpretieren können was aber nicht
bedeutet dass die fans eine verschiedene
ist und das finde ich so spannend auch
und ich würde jesus steht für mich steht
ein stück weit dafür als negativer als
geschichte aber es ist auch da wieder
eine prägung und ja ich sehe wie gesagt
ich will kann ich bin universalist ich
kann wenn da nur christentum ist mich
mit christentum anfreunden genauso wie
muslimische oder jüdisch oder das ist
nicht mein problem ein problem ist
eigentlich eher diese ja wenn es dann in
überheblichkeit geht von wegen ich bin
was besonderes weil ich das was du bist
nicht bin dann kann schon sagen ok de
tessieres wahnsinn
ich finde aber wir müssen aufpassen wenn
wir also es ist wichtig also sachen zu
finden die uns zusammen bringen aber ich
muss trotzdem ein gegenüber in seinem
selbstverständnis ernst nehmen sind
gerade so im interreligiösen dialog
passiert das oft lich also ich
christlich jüdische dialog ist oft so
aufgebaut dass man permanent über alles
redet was halt christentum und judentum
gemeinsam
ergo was das christentum hat also das
ist so geil halt es ist vielleicht
irgendwie man kann daran glauben dass
gott in allem ist aber gewisse
religionen haben ein ganz bestimmtes
gottesbild was nämlich becker das war
meinte ich mit interpretationen jede
kultur hat ihre eigene wunderbare
interpretation und deshalb habe es auch
erwähnt weil diese interpretation
natürlich ein eigenes und auch teils was
was in dem sinne deiner kultur
auffassung zugehörig ist die
interpretation ist das entscheidende
und da würde ich auch nicht ähnlich wie
du sagst das würde ich nicht verwischen
wollen
aber es ist schon klar dass eine
interpretation ist von ansicht der
gleichen eltern ich finde einfach nur
wir sollen halt weg davon gehen zu sagen
die sind alle so gleich und wir wollen
nicht über andersartigkeit reden weil
dann passiert gerade das dass das
andersartige als böse gesehen wird
sondern vielmehr so dass es uns feiern
das haben eine andere interpretation
hast und ich bin andere interpreten aber
hier finden wir uns okay von der bahn
der andersartigkeit ja finde ich keine
da ist mal gemeinsamkeit wenn ich die
basis gemeinsamkeit habe um dann meine
andersartigkeit erkläre kommen wir aber
von einer basis auf die andersartigkeit
sein also weil das ist sozusagen auf was
wir uns einigen können nämlich so wir
sind ja anders als die anderen also
jeder einzelne ist ja total anderen
müssen wir dürfen aber natürlich nicht
und ich glaube da verstehe ich dich wir
dürfen nicht so identität politisch nur
noch so uns verkapseln licht und keine
keine keine solidarität mehr
untereinander spüren sondern uns nur
noch sozusagen das hätte ich das mandat
des reichen wenn du über migranten
sierte menschen oder über jüdische
menschen herz schießt und meinst du
kannst die demütigen und glaubst dass
das nicht weh tut und wenn ich sehe dass
dann wieder gehe ein riesenfass auf
machst darüber mal hat mich verletzt
dann weiß ja wie ich mich fühle
wir haben also eine gemeinsamkeit
demütigung tut weh und es nicht in
ordnung und diese gemeinsamkeit die
meine ich also das ist die gemeinsamkeit
nicht die verschiedenheit der
interpretation die ich als total
reichtum absoluten reichtum empfinden
aber aber dann okay dann
dann bin ich finde ich gut dann finde
ich muss doch einfach tatsächlich auch
ein bisschen darüber nachgedacht werden
wie das konkret dann aussehen kann das
eben diese unterschiedlichen
ausschließung nicht mehr stattfinden
generell geht es für mich er sozusagen
darum nicht also mit einer ich weiß ich
weiß dass ich nicht nichts weiß
einstellung auf den anderen zuzugehen
das heißt ich weiß nicht was du feierst
deswegen fand ich schön wenn man erst
mal fragt was machst du denn während
dieser zeit vielleicht feiert diese
person kein weihnachten weil sie jüdin
oder jude ist oder muslimen und ist
total alleine zu hause war die ganze
familie weg ist und wie schön wird es
dann zu sagen vielleicht solltest du
irgendwie ich würde gerne desto mit mir
weihnachten feiert oder so also für mich
geht's erst mal darum zu sagen okay was
tust du um dann herauszufinden wie
dieser mensch lebt was der während
dieser zeit tut ob der feiert oder nicht
feiert auch da suche ich mir ja auch so
ein bisschen aus auf was ich jetzt
eigentlich bock haben
da wurde sicher sind bei auf dich zu
bewegt ich würde auch gern mal bevor wir
zu den lösung kommen eine letzte frage
vielleicht an dich hanna wie viel hat
denn weihnachten überhaupt noch mit
christlichkeit und religion zu tun weil
wir sprechen jetzt die ganze zeit über
diese christliche dominanz gibt es die
überhaupt noch also hat weihnachten
überhaupt noch irgendetwas damit zu tun
wenn wir in deutschland durchschnittlich
zu weihnachten 500 euro für geschenke
ausgeben
ich glaub ich finde das ganz gut weil es
wir haben anfang gar nicht geklärt haben
was wir unter dem weihnachts begriff
jetzt verstehen ich glaube also mit dem
religiösen weihnachts begriff so wie ich
ihn verstehe und wie viele andere
christinnen und christen die den
gottesdienst gehen denen das wichtig ist
verstehen hat das heutige weihnachten
nicht mehr viel zu tun weil es ja wie
gesagt schon im november beginnt und man
noch viel früher irgendwie süßigkeiten
kaufen kann und das dann eine sehr lange
zeit ist und eigentlich ist zum beispiel
die adventszeit vor weihnachten auch
eine fastenzeit wo man sich darauf
vorbereitet und wo man eigentlich eher
irgendwie sich besinnt um dann
weihnachten richtig feiern zu können und
das ist ja auch was den wenigsten leuten
heute irgendwie noch bewusst ist ich
möchte gerne zu den lösungsvorschlägen
kommen ich habe 34 euch dabei und ich
bin mal gespannt ob jetzt gleich alle
hier so am rand im kompromiss feld steht
also erste frage von 13 fragen können
wir uns darauf einigen dass kulturelle
vielfalt auch gefeiert werden muss
wollen wir also einen neuen feiertag
einführen der religionsübergreifend ist
und zb der feiertag der vielfalt ist was
sagt ihr kommt ihr auf mich zu
schließlich schon du bist schon dann
okay ich bin bereit zwölfte frage von 13
fragen
niemand sollte gezwungen werden
weihnachten zu feiern wenn er oder sie
kein weihnachten feiern will
wie wäre es also wenn alle an drei
zusätzlichen religiösen feiertagen frei
nehmen könnten und diese selbst
entscheiden können warum soll drei
vielen anderen weltanschauungen und
religionen nicht gerecht wird und dass
immer noch irgendwie also zum beispiel
ich feiere auch weihnachten ja so um
säkularisierten sinne geht es ja gar
nicht darum weihnachten abzufeuern
also abzuschaffen nicht aber das ist
halt immer noch nur dominanz von
christlicher seite dann wäre das nicht
einschritt womit man anfang könnte oder
würdest du sagen nee da stimme ich nur
zu wenn es sechs tage werden oder
grundsätzlich scheiße nicht
grundsätzlich scheiße 3 ist zu wenig
verbrauch zu wenig sage ich ehrlich okay
man sich der sind wirklich gut aber ich
kann rebecca da wirklich zustimmt das 33
okay was wäre dann für euch gut ein
gutes beispiel woche für ich bin monat
im jahr sollte man schon feiern
es ist jetzt schwierig würde müssen das
stimmt aber ich kann es aus fragen
möchten wir den anstieg aber dafür
bräuchten wir eine antikapitalistische
gesellschaft vielleicht die so etwas
überhaupt zu lesen kann einfach so den
kündigungsschutz geben also wenn ich
halte am gipfel frei nehmen wir darf das
kein kündigungsgrund sein
ok ich mich kümmere ich mich darum
dreizehnte frage von 13 fragen können
wir uns darauf einigen dass wir im
religionsunterricht auch das bewusstsein
für andere religionen als nur die
christliche feiern wollen um damit eben
das bewusstsein für diese zu schärfen
was sagt ihr
muss das im religion ihr sonst auch der
religionskriege wo dann warum ich tätig
und habe ich dann streichen wie
religionen und ersetzen das politikum
seid ihr alle sehr gut da können wir
doch die moschee im dorf stehen ja nicht
so schlimm alles ja dann
vielen dank euch allen und schöne
weihnachten nicht schöne weine wir
wollen danke ich fand das war eine ganz
starke runde weil man die
unterschiedlichkeiten kann da die alle
mitgebracht haben also ich hab gerade
eben noch gedacht werden wir uns alle
nur digital auf twitter begegnet hätten
wir uns irgendwie vermutlich beleidigt
und am ende gegenseitig blockiert und
ich fand sehr schön zu erleben wie wir
unterschiedliche positionen hatten immer
wieder uns angenähert haben uns entfernt
haben und das aber ausgehalten haben
auch unterschiedliche positionen zu
vertreten
es hat mir noch mal gezeigt wie wichtig
es ist dass wir der gesellschaft ein
größeres bewusstsein für
unterschiedliche meinungen und
unterschiedliche religionen und
weltanschauungen geben
ich glaube wenn wir uns andere feiertage
von anderen kulturen oder religionen an
schon profitieren wir eben von der
vielfalt der gesellschaft wir lernen
neues kennen können mehr feiern wir
können mehr essen weil ich vielleicht zu
neuen feiertag eingeladen werden und wir
können halt einfach erleben wie
bereichernd
eine multikulturelle diverse
gesellschaft ist
also gerade diesem jahr fertig sind wir
sehr nah dran am ersten weihnachtsfest
da lief nämlich auch vieles anders als
geplant
es gab keine keine herberge für maria
und josef und es gab kein baby wird für
jesus sondern es gab einfach eine
futterkrippe und trotzdem wurde
improvisiert und das beste draus gemacht
und die liebe gottes setzt sich immer
durch auch in schwierigen zeiten und
unter widrigen umständen und das ist
etwas was mich für dieses weihnachtsfest
sehr tröstet dass es nicht von perfekten
umständen abhängen sondern davon dass
gott mit uns vorhat und was wir daraus
machen
ich verstehe dann wird es schön nochmal
mit besonders schön machen aber
perfektionisten handeln selten aus
harmonie gründen sondern eher aus ego
gründen oder vielleicht auch ja also man
will unbedingt perfekt sein und so also
wir alle diesen stress haben
perfektionismus stress an weihnachten
möchte sagen habe die einfach mit ihr
machen hast du dingsbums apodiktisch du
bist nicht perfekt war das kann ich dir
sagen
also eigentlich würde ich die
vorstellung ganz gut mehr feiertage zu
haben
wie geht's euch dann hat diese
diskussion vielleicht sogar eure meinung
zum thema weihnachten geändert dann
schreibt es mir sehr sehr gerne in die
kommentare
falls euch diese folge gefallen hat
würde es mich natürlich total freuen
wenn ihr diesen kanal abonniert und wenn
ihr mehr von 13 fragen sehen wollt
findet ihr das hier oben und ein
weiteres video zum thema hier unten